and so that all hikari can do is just
retreat his rook
is hikari going to resign do you think i
mean no there's equal material on the
board but
if you compare the peak quality there's
no killer blow
as of yet i mean it looks disgusting i
think black has to lose material
how is black gonna save his rook so
black rook in the corner there in
white's half
no matter where it goes it's gonna get
captured it's gonna get trapped uh it
sacrifices itself for a bishop
um so now magnus is a rook for a bishop
up and white still has that powerful
pawn
white still has a beautiful knight in
the center of the board yes black has
been able to
ruin the pawn structure of round white's
king but there are no pieces to attack
that white king that's the key
a king is only as weak as the piece as
uh as the pieces are
around to attack it so yeah hikaru using
the black queen there to blockade
white's pawn
you can tell on hikari's face it's yeah
it's not gone well the last few moves
he's in survival mode he's just trying
to
cling on now and i hope that magnus gets
nervous while the clock stick down but
that rarely happens okay